This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. For generations, gay people were the target of noxious stereotypes in the United States. Quarters in the homosexuals. The second you see your son dropping the limperist, you rock over there and crack that wrist. Halls of worship and airwaves were full of hateful propaganda. AIDS is the judgment of God, and that's the title of the sermon tonight. AIDS, the judgment of God.
这里是 Hidden Brain，我是香卡·韦丹塔。世世代代以来，同性恋者在美国一直是恶毒刻板印象的目标。同性恋者的聚居区。你儿子只要一出现娘娘腔的举止，你就得冲过去，打他那只手腕。礼拜堂和广播里充斥着充满仇恨的宣传。艾滋病是上帝的审判，这就是今晚布道的标题。艾滋病，上帝的审判。
Build a great, big, large fence for all the lesbians in there. Gay rights advocates are outraged over a ruling yesterday by a Virginia judge which denied a mother custody of her son because she's a lesbian. The judge said the relationship is, in his words, illegal and immoral. Illegal and immoral. Illegal and immoral. And have that fifth-selectified, so they can't get out and feed them.
给那里的所有女同性恋者建造一个又大又宽的栅栏。同性恋权利倡导者对弗吉尼亚州法官昨天做出的一项裁决感到愤怒，该裁决剥夺了一位母亲对儿子的抚养权，因为她是女同性恋。法官用他的话说，这段关系是违法的、不道德的。违法的和不道德的。违法的和不道德的。并对其进行第五阶段的筛选，这样他们就无法出来养活他们。
And you know what, in a few years they'll die. In classrooms, workplaces, and social settings, homophobes targeted gay people with violence. And Matthew Shepherd was beaten last weekend, tied to a wooden fence by two men who met Shepherd in a bar in Laramie, Wyoming. 18 hours later, a passing bicyclist, summoned help after almost mistaking
而且你知道吗，几年后他们就会死。在教室、工作场所和社会环境中，恐同者以暴力针对同性恋者。马修·谢帕德上周末遭到殴打，被两个在怀俄明州拉勒米的一家酒吧认识谢帕德的男子绑在木栅栏上。18小时后，一名路过的骑自行车的人在几乎误认了
Shepherd's bloody body for a scarecrow There were few places to escape homophobia was widespread throughout the Western world being accomplished or brilliant was no defense Alan Turing the mathematician who helped the allies win the Second World War by working to crack Hitler's the allies win the Second World War by working to crack Hitler's communication codes, was prosecuted by the British government for having a sexual relationship with another man. The state gave him two options, prison or chemical castration. He chose the chemicals. 16 days before his 42nd birthday, he killed himself.
谢帕德血淋淋的身体就像一个稻草人。几乎没有什么地方可以逃脱恐同情绪，这种情绪在整个西方世界广泛存在，取得成就或才华横溢也不是防御的手段。阿兰·图灵这位帮助盟军赢得第二次世界大战的数学家，通过努力破解希特勒的通讯密码，被英国政府起诉，因为他与另一个男人保持着性关系。国家给了他两个选择，监狱或化学阉割。他选择了化学阉割。在他42岁生日的前16天，他自杀了。
15 days before his 42nd birthday, he killed himself. The pain of the past is not the focus of our episode today. It is only the backdrop, but it is necessary to see this backdrop clearly to understand something very new and very surprising. Things have changed dramatically in the United States when it comes to attitudes about gay people. This is actually one of the most surprising things in the whole history of public opinion in the United States. What we see in attitudes towards gay rights is a really stunning change of her time sooner than almost anybody thought possible.
在他42岁生日的前15天，他自杀了。过去的痛苦不是我们今天节目的重点。这只是背景，但清楚地看到这个背景对于理解一些非常新颖和非常令人惊讶的事情是必要的。在美国，人们对同性恋者的态度发生了巨大变化。这实际上是美国公众舆论史上最令人惊讶的事情之一。我们在对待同性恋权利的态度上看到的是，随着时间的推移，发生了惊人的变化，其速度比几乎任何人想象的都要快。
This week on Hidden Brain, this is huge. The psychological strategies behind one of the most dramatic transformations of public attitude ever recorded. How can it be that an attitude that was as vicious as this one has changed? Laurie Lightfoot becomes the first black woman and the first openly gay person ever elected mayor in Chicago.
本周在 Hidden Brain 上，这太巨大了。有史以来记录的公众态度最戏剧性转变背后的心理策略。这样一个恶毒的态度怎么会发生改变呢？洛丽·莱特福特成为芝加哥有史以来第一位当选市长的黑人女性和第一位公开同性恋身份的人。
Each of you, one day, can be the mayor of Chicago. Thank Buddha Judge, and his 37 years old, and he is running for president. The most important thing in my life, my marriage to Chast, is something that exists by the grace of a single vote on the U.S. Supreme Court. Love, commitment, family, inclusion. And the surprising lessons, the story holds, for anyone who seeks to bring about change, dignity, respect, normalcy, liberation, not assimilation. When William Cox was a child, he noticed something about the world. So I'm in a family of five and we're all adopted. I'd observe how my sister, who's very dark-skinned, got treated differently than her twin brother, who's very light-skinned.
你们每个人，总有一天，都可以成为芝加哥市长。布达法官，他37岁，正在竞选总统。我生命中最重要的事情，我与查斯特的婚姻，是美国最高法院单票通过而存在的。爱、承诺、家庭、包容。这个故事对于任何寻求带来改变、尊严、尊重、正常化、解放（而不是同化）的人来说，都蕴含着令人惊讶的教训。威廉·考克斯（William Cox）小时候，他注意到了世界上的某些事情。所以我生活在一个五口之家，我们都是被收养的。我观察到我的姐姐，她皮肤很黑，与她皮肤很白的双胞胎兄弟相比，受到的待遇是如何不同的。
People would see him as white and treat him completely differently than how they would treat her because they perceived her as black or Hispanic. In time, William discovered that like his sister, he too was an outsider. As I grew up, I came to realize that I was gay and then that in and of itself brought about different treatment. The challenge in Williams case wasn't just at school. My parents are Mormon, and Mormons are not very much in favor of people being gay, and so that created a lot of conflict with us. They came up to them when I was 18, and living at home and still going to college. It became just a big argument that I don't know, I was being influenced by society.
人们会把他视为白人，并以完全不同于对待她的方式对待他，因为他们认为她是黑人或西班牙裔。随着时间的推移，威廉发现像他的姐姐一样，他也是一个局外人。随着我长大，我开始意识到自己是同性恋，这本身就带来了不同的对待。威廉面临的挑战不仅仅是在学校。我的父母是摩门教徒，摩门教徒非常不支持同性恋，所以这给我们之间带来了很多冲突。在我18岁、住在家里且还在上大学的时候，他们走过来找我。这变成了一场大争吵，我不知道，我当时受到了社会的熏陶。
I remember they blamed Will and Grace was one of the things that came up in the argument. And it was just kind of, it was kind of incoherent because it was a big yelling crying sort of a fair. As they argued, he says they kept discovering new things to disagree about. William told his parents that given the church's views on homosexuality, he had no interest in going on the traditional mission trip when he was 18.
我记得他们指责《威尔和格蕾丝》（Will and Grace）是争论中出现的事情之一。这有点，有点语无伦次，因为那是一场大喊大叫、哭哭啼啼的事件。在他们争论时，他说他们不断发现新的事情来意见不合。威廉告诉他的父母，鉴于教会对同性恋的看法，他18岁时对参加传统的传教之旅没有任何兴趣。
I mean, then one day my dad and I were driving home from somewhere and gotten a big fight. It was about religion again. And my dad said, uh, you just love stabbing us in the heart, don't you? Something like that. And I said to him, don't be so dramatic. And then he pulled over the car, took my backpack out of the back seat and tossed it in the ditch on the side road and said, that's dramatic. William got out of the car. He says his father drove off, leaving him clutching his backpack by the side of the road. How did you get home that day? I didn't. So that's kind of one of those moments in life where what he later says is that he had just expected me to walk the rest of the way home.
我的意思是，有一天我和爸爸开车从某个地方回家，大吵了一架。又是关于宗教的事。我爸爸说，呃，你就是喜欢捅我们的心，对吧？诸如此类的话。我对他说，别这么戏剧化。然后他把车停在路边，从后座拿走我的背包，把它扔在路边的沟里，说，这才是戏剧化的。威廉下了车。他说他父亲开车走了，留下他独自一人抓着背包站在路边。那天你是怎么回家的？我没有。所以这可以说是生活中的那些时刻之一，他后来所说的是，他本以为我会自己走完剩下的路回家。
And I just kind of, I guess I went into, I don't know, crisis mode or what, I just kind of shut off a lot of the emotional reaction. I was just like, well, what are the next steps? What do I need to do? He knew he needed a place to stay. And he needed to complete a school assignment. I had a friend who worked at a hotel downtown
我当时大概进入了，我不知道，危机模式还是什么，我只是差不多关闭了很多情绪反应。我当时想，好吧，下一步是什么？我需要做什么？他知道自己需要一个住处。他需要完成一份学校作业。我有一个在市中心一家酒店工作的朋友
and I went there and used their business center to finish a paper that was doing my English class the next day. And then I mean I was, I was, I was homeless for a little while. I slept on friends' couches, things like that. Got a job at Wendy's and stayed in school. And here I am now. William became a social psychologist at the University of Wisconsin-Madison. He studies stereotypes.
我去了那里，使用他们的商务中心完成了一篇第二天要交的英语课论文。然后我的意思是，我，我，我无家可归了一段时间。我睡在朋友的沙发上，诸如此类的。在温蒂汉堡（Wendy's）找了份工作，继续上学。这就是现在的我。威廉成为了威斯康星大学麦迪逊分校的社会心理学家。他研究刻板印象。
It's been more than 15 years since that incident on the road with his father. I asked him how things turned out with his parents. My dad, you know, he got very hot that moment, but he's a very loving man and he loves me and has apologized and I know he really regrets what happened. Over time, William says his father started to look at gay rights through a new frame. He had been a high school history teacher and had been deeply influenced by Martin Luther King Jr. and the Civil Rights Movement. After this kind of emotional period right after I came out, he started drawing parallels to LGBT people are going through to the civil rights movement
距离他在路上与父亲发生那起事件已经过去15年多了。我问他与父母的关系结果如何。我爸爸，你知道，那一刻他非常生气，但他是一个非常慈爱的人，他爱我，也已经道歉了，我知道他真的很后悔发生的事。随着时间的推移，威廉说他的父亲开始通过一个新的框架来看待同性恋权利。他曾是一名高中历史老师，深受马丁·路德·金和小民权运动的影响。在我出柜后经历的这段情绪激动的时期之后，他开始将LGBT群体正在经历的事情与民权运动进行平行对比。
and I think his overarching principles of fairness really kind of started shining through with relation to this. Things have changed so much that William now looks forward to gatherings with his parents. When I first spoke to him, it was in the fall. And they're coming down to have Thanksgiving at my house with me and my partner in a couple weeks. From throwing out your son on the side of a road, to sitting down to Thanksgiving dinner son and his partner. The Ark of William's story mirrors a dramatic change across the United States. This is actually one of the most surprising things in the whole history of public opinion. Michael Rosenfeld is a sociologist at Stanford.
我认为他关于公平的最高原则确实开始在这方面闪耀光芒。事情发生了如此大的变化，以至于威廉现在非常期待与父母的聚会。我第一次和他交谈时，是在秋天。几周后，他们要下来和我和伴侣在我家过感恩节。从把你的儿子扔在路边，到和儿子及他的伴侣坐在一起吃感恩节晚餐。威廉故事的轨迹反映了全美范围内的巨大变化。这实际上是公众舆论史上最令人惊讶的事情之一。迈克尔·罗森feld（Michael Rosenfeld）是斯坦福大学的社会学家。
There's more and more rapid change in attitudes towards gay rights in the past 30 years in the United States than there ever has been in recorded attitudes in the United States on any issue. Michael cites data from the General Social Survey, one of the most important and reliable ways of tracking over time how Americans think. They have a pretty good history of long time frame of asking the same questions about gay rights over time. Let's take one specific question. Starting in the late 1980s, the General Social Survey periodically asked Americans whether gay people should have the right to marry. In 1988, when the General Social Survey first asked the question about same-sex marriage,
在过去的30年里，美国对同性恋权利态度的变化越来越快，这是美国有记录以来对任何议题的态度变化所从未有过的。迈克尔引用了综合社会调查（General Social Survey）的数据，这是追踪美国人长期以来想法的最重要、最可靠的方法之一。他们有着相当好的长期历史记录，能够随着时间推移提出关于同性恋权利的相同问题。让我们举一个具体的问题。从20世纪80年代末开始，综合社会调查定期询问美国人同性恋者是否应该拥有结婚的权利。1988年，当综合社会调查首次提出关于同性婚姻的问题时，
only 11.6% of respondents said that they thought same-sex couples should have the right to marry. And you have to remember, 11.6% is almost as low as you can get. It's hard to get less than 5% on any question, so 11.6% is really everyone was against it almost. But by 2018, the number of Americans who set same-sex couples should have the right to marry was 68%. That's a really dramatic change. It's rare for public opinion on contested issues to change that much.
只有11.6%的受访者表示他们认为同性伴侣应该有权结婚。你必须记住，11.6%几乎是你能得到的最低比例。在任何问题上都很难得到低于5%的支持，所以11.6%真的意味着几乎所有人都反对。但到2018年，表示同性伴侣应该有权结婚的美国人比例达到了68%。这是一个非常巨大的变化。有争议问题的公众舆论发生如此大的变化是罕见的。
At first, survey researchers thought that what was happening with gay rights was only generational change. Younger people, with more liberal attitudes, were giving survey researchers different answers than older people with more conservative attitudes. But when Michael looked at the data, he found lots and lots of people like William's parents. People who, in a matter of years, had fundamentally changed their outlook. Even though it was sort of Democrats and liberals who were more likely to be open to gay rights, it turns out that there were plenty of evangelical Christians, rural people, Republican voters,
起初，调查研究人员认为，同性恋权利所发生的事情只是一种代际变化。态度更自由的年轻研究对象，给出的调查答案与态度更保守的老年人不同。但当迈克尔查看数据时，他发现了许许多多像威廉父母这样的人。这些人几年之内从根本上改变了他们的观点。尽管民主党人和自由主义者更有可能对同性恋权利持开放态度，但事实证明，有大量的福音派基督徒、农村居民、共和党选民，
who actually changed their mind on these issues. Now you can argue that public opinion can sometimes change quickly. During wartime, views about an enemy can intensify from negative feelings to outright hatred. But when was the last time you heard of half the country reversing its views on an important issue? Tens of millions of people believing one thing and then like a light switch being flipped believing exactly the opposite. That almost never happens. William Cox argues that the most surprising change is not the one that unfolded in courts and legislatures. It is in the change in attitudes, in workplaces, in families, in schools.
实际上在这个问题上改变了他们的主意。现在你可以争辩说，公众舆论有时会迅速改变。在战争时期，对敌人的看法会从负面情绪加剧到彻头彻尾的仇恨。但你上一次听说半个国家对一个重要问题的看法发生逆转是什么时候？数以千万计的人先是相信一件事，然后就像按了一下电灯开关一样，相信完全相反的事情。这几乎从未发生过。威廉·考克斯认为，最令人惊讶的变化不是在法庭和立法机构中展开的，而是在工作场所、家庭、学校中态度的改变。
When I was in high school, I didn't know a single person who was out. And by sheer numbers, there should have been about 200 gay men in the school. Now, kids very often are coming out in middle school or even before. And so just the visibility of gay people has shifted enormously over the past 10, 15, 20 years. Of course, there are many parts of the world where coming out as gay is still dangerous, and there are many pockets of prejudice throughout the United States, but the tide has turned dramatically. Psychological tests show that what people are seeing and doing is mirrored by changes in their brains.
当我上高中时，我不认识任何一个出柜的人。按纯粹的人数计算，学校里应该有大约200名同性恋男性。现在，孩子们经常在初中甚至更早的时候就出柜了。因此，过去10年、15年、20年里，同性恋者的能见度发生了巨大变化。当然，世界上许多地方出柜仍然是危险的，美国各地也有许多偏见残余，但潮流已经发生了巨大的转变。心理测试表明，人们所看到和做到的事情反映在大脑的变化中。
For roughly two decades Harvard psychologist Maserine Banaji has tracked what she calls the implicit or hidden prejudices of millions of Americans. Her test measures attitudes toward a number of groups. Over the last decade, there has been one dramatic change. So the most surprising result comes from the sexuality test. What we see there on the implicit attitude, okay? I'm not talking now about what people say. I'm talking about what the automatic response is on the test. We see a 33% drop in anti-gay bias.
大约二十年来，哈佛大学心理学家玛萨琳·巴纳吉（Mahzarin Banaji）一直在追踪她所谓的数百万美国人的内隐偏见或隐藏偏见。她的测试衡量了对许多群体的态度。在过去十年中，有一个巨大的变化。因此，最令人惊讶的结果来自性倾向测试。我们在内隐态度上看到的，对吧？我现在不是在谈论人们说什么。我谈论的是测试中的自动反应。我们看到反同性恋偏见下降了33%。
This is huge. If researchers like Michael and Marzarene sound a little stunned by their data, it's because they are. This was not a simple negative attitude. K people have been killed. So how can it be that an attitude that was as vicious as this one has changed?
这太巨大了。如果像迈克尔和玛萨琳这样的研究人员对他们的感到有点震惊，那是因为他们确实如此。这不仅仅是一种简单的消极态度。同性恋者被杀害了。那么，这样一个恶毒的态度怎么会发生改变呢？
In a thought experiment, Maserine and her colleagues have extended the trend lines of the data to see how long it would take for bias to be entirely eliminated. To be clear, this isn't a prediction about what is going to happen. It just shows you the speed at which different biases are changing. The forecast show that if things go swimmingly well in nine years,
在一个思想实验中，玛萨琳和她的同事扩展了数据的趋势线，以观察偏见完全消除需要多长时间。需要明确的是，这并不是对将要发生的事情的预测。它只是向你展示了不同偏见正在改变的速度。预测显示，如果一切顺利，在九年内，
anti-gay attitudes will be all but eliminated, that we will reach neutrality. By contrast, when it comes to race issues, the projections are, it will take nearly six decades for Americans to see blacks and whites the same way. Biasis about skin tone, preferences for lighter skin over darker skin, that should take 138 years if current trends persist. Biasis against the elderly, Aegeism? Here is Tessa Charlesworth, a researcher working with Maasarene. Implicit age attitudes will not reach neutrality,
反同性恋态度将几乎完全消除，我们将达到中立状态。相比之下，在种族问题上，预测显示，美国人需要近六个世纪才能以相同的方式看待黑人和白人。如果目前的趋势持续下去，对肤色的偏见、对浅色皮肤胜过深色皮肤的偏好，需要138年。对老龄人口的偏见，年龄歧视？这里是与玛萨琳合作的研究员苔莎·查尔斯沃思（Tessa Charlesworth）。内隐年龄态度不会达到中立状态，
even within the next 150 years. Aegeism, and prejudice to what people with disabilities and those who are overweight, appear to be rampant and stubbornly persistent. What do you think drove the remarkable change in attitudes to what gay people? Maserine says she asks herself that question all the time. I was in London this summer watching from my hotel room a pride parade. And I was mesmerized. Happiness everywhere.
甚至在未来150年内也不会。年龄歧视，以及对残疾人和超重人群的偏见，似乎仍然猖獗且极其顽固。你认为是什么推动了对同性恋者态度的显著改变？玛萨琳说她一直在问自己这个问题。今年夏天我在伦敦的酒店房间里观看了一场骄傲游行。我被迷住了。到处都是快乐。
London police marching, gay police and straight police in support of gay police. I saw banners of, you know, the largest for-profit corporations in the world marching, Goldman Sachs, PWC, EY, each with their own banners. And I asked myself, what would a Black Lives Matter parade look like? Would the police be marching? Would these corporations have a banner in a parade of that kind? I doubt it.
伦敦警察在游行，同性恋警察和直男警察一起支持同性恋警察。我看到了一些旗标，你知道的，世界上规模最大的营利性公司也在游行，高盛、普华永道、安永，每个公司都有自己的旗标。我问自己，“黑人的命也是命”游行会是什么样子？警察会游行吗？这些公司会在那种游行中打出旗标吗？我对此表示怀疑。
So yes, something is happened, but to us the question is why. On June 28, 1969, police raided a bar in New York City, the Stonewall Inn. For decades, gay bars like this one had been targeted by police raids. Anti-Satami laws made it a criminal offense to live openly as a gay person in most places in the United States. But on that steamy summer night, under the glow of a full moon, something changed. Witnesses said that it's police drag people out, one woman shouted out to her fellow patrons.
所以是的，事情确实发生了，但对我们来说问题是为什么。1969年6月28日，警察突袭了纽约市的一家酒吧——石墙客栈。几十年来，像这样的同性恋酒吧一直是警方突袭的目标。反鸡奸法使得在美国大部分地区公开以同性恋身份生活成为一种刑事犯罪。但在那个闷热的夏夜，在满月的微光下，事情发生了变化。目击者称，警察把人们拖出来，一个女人向她的同伴大喊：
Why don't you guys do something? Why don't you guys do something? Why don't you guys do something? They did. Riots broke out. Within an hour, the surrounding streets was surging with people. Police were outnumbered. They sought shelter inside the very bar they had come to raid. People threw bricks, they smashed windows, but there was a creative energy. The rioters were building something new, demolishing an old structure to make way for a new one with fewer closets.
你们为什么不做点什么？你们为什么不做点什么？你们为什么不做点什么？他们做了。骚乱爆发了。不到一个小时，周围的街道上就挤满了人。警察人数处于劣势。他们在他们原本要突袭的那家酒吧里寻求庇护。人们扔砖头，砸碎窗户，但有一种创造性的能量。暴徒们正在建立一些新的东西，拆除旧结构，为几乎没有衣橱的新结构让路。
Many historians locate the start of the modern gay rights movement to the Stonewall riots. Of course, history doesn't come with a start date. You can go back further and find examples of activism. But Stonewall was a pivotal moment. Gay people were saying, enough, stop harassing us. But the protest also did something else. Sociologist Michael Rosenfeld says, for the first time in the lives of many Americans,
许多历史学家将现代同性恋权利运动的起点定位为石墙骚乱。当然，历史并没有一个起始日期。你可以追溯到更早的时期并找到行动主义的例子。但石墙是一个关键时刻。同性恋者在说，够了，别再骚扰我们了。但这场抗议也起到了另一个作用。社会学家迈克尔·罗森feld说，在许多美国人有生以来第一次，
gay people were making themselves visible. It's in the period when gay and lesbian people come out of the closet that straight Americans attitudes about gay rights really start to shift. It turned out that gay people had a singular advantage that many racial minorities do not. Gay people were embedded within the homes and the communities of those who thought gay people were an abomination. Most gay and lesbian people have heterosexual parents. So within the same family, you have relatives
同性恋者让自己变得可见。正是在男同性恋和女同性恋出柜的时期，直男美国人对同性恋权利的态度才真正开始转变。事实证明，同性恋者拥有许多种族少数群体所没有的独特优势。同性恋者融入了那些认为同性恋者是可憎之人的家庭和社区中。大多数男同性恋和女同性恋都有异性恋父母。所以在同一个家庭里，你既有亲戚
who are gay and relatives who are straight, whereas the family system segregates not completely, but almost completely, whites from blacks. And then it's also true that because gays and lesbians are in the same families as heterosexual people, they have the same socioeconomic background, and they're geographically integrated with them. So there were just a lot of more opportunities for straight people to meet gay people who were similar status to themselves. Parents with gay kids often had to grapple with the form of cognitive dissonance.
是同性恋，也有亲戚是异性恋，而家庭系统并没有完全隔离，但几乎完全隔离了白人和黑人。而且同样真实的是，因为男同性恋和女同性恋与异性恋者属于同一个家庭，他们有着相同的社会经济背景，并且在地理上与他们融合在一起。因此，对于直男来说，有很多更多的机会去结识与自己地位相似的同性恋者。有同性恋孩子的父母经常不得不应对一种形式的认知失调。
As psychologist Mazareen Banaji says, many parents were forced to choose between their love for their children and their pre-existing attitudes about homosexuality. Many people have changed their attitudes towards the group because a child came out. In any reckoning of why attitudes toward gay people change so fast, coming out of the closet is a central part of the story. But of course, this doesn't entirely explain the mystery of why anti-gay attitudes have declined so dramatically. Think about other groups that face persistent discrimination in our society. Old people are found across all income groups and black and white families in all parts of the country. Like many gay people, the elderly have had long associations with others before they became elderly.
正如心理学家玛萨琳·巴纳吉所说，许多父母被迫在对孩子的爱和他们对同性恋既有的态度之间做出选择。许多人改变了对这个群体的态度，因为一个孩子出柜了。在计算为什么对同性恋者的态度变化如此之快时，出柜是故事的核心部分。但当然，这并不能完全解释为什么反同性恋态度会急剧下降的谜团。想想我们社会中面临持续歧视的其他群体。老年人存在于所有收入阶层以及全国各地的黑人和白人家庭中。就像许多同性恋者一样，老年人在他们变老之前与其他人群有着长期的联系。
And yet, as we noted earlier, implicit biases against old people have hardly budged. Implicit age attitudes will not reach neutrality even within the next 150 years. Or consider women. They are also embedded in the homes of people who are a vowed misogynist. Women's deep connections and daily presence as moms and sisters and wives and daughters and friends and colleagues have not eradicated the persistence of inequality and abuse. People around the world are coming forward on social media to share their stories of sexual abuse. I think me too. Me too.
然而，正如我们前面所指出的，针对老年人的内隐偏见几乎没有动摇。内隐年龄态度甚至在未来150年内都不会达到中立。或者考虑女性。她们也融入了公开厌女症患者的家庭中。女性作为母亲、姐妹、妻子、女儿、朋友和同事的深厚联系和日常存在，并没有根除不平等和虐待的持续存在。世界各地的人们都在社交媒体上挺身而出，分享他们遭受性虐待的故事。我想我也是。我也是。
Women are consistently paid less than men. Maternal wall referring to discrimination against hiring or promoting mothers, based on these subjects. I never reported it. I concealed my injuries and taught the next morning, me too. What explains the very different trajectory in our attitudes to what gay people? Scientists at the National Centers for Disease Control
女性的收入总是比男性低。母职壁垒指的是基于这些主题对雇用或晋升母亲的歧视。我从未报告过。我隐瞒了我的伤痛并在第二天早晨去上课，我也是。是什么解释了我们对同性恋者态度的截然不同轨迹？国家疾病控制中心
and Atlanta today released the results of a study which shows that the lifestyle of some male homosexuals has triggered an epidemic of a rare form of cancer. One answer lies in the response to a crisis that befell the gay community and especially gay men in the 1980s, AIDS broke the silence about who gay people are. This is gay rights activist, Evan Wolfson. It led non-gay people to see gay people as members of families, as parts of couples, as people who were grieving,
亚特兰大今天发布的科学研究结果显示，一些男性同性恋者的生活方式引发了一场罕见癌症的流行。一个答案在于对20世纪80年代降临到同性恋社群特别是男同性恋身上的危机的反应，艾滋病打破了关于同性恋者是谁的沉默。这是同性恋权利活动家埃文·沃尔夫森（Evan Wolfson）。它让非同性恋者看到同性恋者是家庭成员、伴侣的一部分、悲伤的人，
as people who were fighting, who were working to care for one another, struggling against discrimination, having courage, and dignity in the face of awful death, it prompted gay people to understand our vulnerability in being excluded from institutions and law such as marriage. It changed our movement from being a movement about wanting to be basically let alone, don't harass us, don't attack us, don't persecute us, into a movement about being let in. We want to be part of, we want to participate, we want to share.
作为正在战斗的人、努力照顾彼此的人、与歧视作斗争的人，在可怕的死亡面前表现出勇气和尊严的人，它促使同性恋者了解我们在被排除在机构和法律（如婚姻）之外时的脆弱性。它改变了我们的运动，从一个想要基本上被独自放过的运动——不要骚扰我们，不要攻击我们，不要迫害我们——变成了一个关于被允许进入的运动。我们想要成为一部分，我们想要参与，我们想要分享。
The epidemic also galvanized organizing efforts. Fight back, fight it! And up! Fight back, fight it! And three will be gone. Take it a bus, did nothing wrong. Take it three, will be gone. Take it a bus, did nothing wrong. Did he see, can't you see? Us, yes, say, hi, we, see. Activists carried ashes of dead family members
这一流行病还激发了组织工作。反击，反击！站起来！反击，反击！三个将不复存在。坐公车，没做错。拿走三个，将不复存在。坐公车，没做错。他看见了吗，你看不见吗？我们，是的，说，嗨，我们，看见了。活动家们带着死去家庭成员的骨灰
and flung them on the lawn of the White House. Bring the dead to your door. Come, take it, keep it up. Bring the dead to your door. family members and flung them on the lawn of the White House. We won't take it any more. We charge you with genocide. Protester has disrupted scientific meetings to demand better medical care. About 20 people sat down blocking a four-lane street. Blocked drivers became angry. By the summer of 1992 protests began to translate into recognition on the political stage. To waste. And yet for too long, politicians have told the most of us that are doing all right, that what's really wrong with America is the rest of us.
并将它们撒在白宫的草坪上。把死者带到你家门口。来吧，拿着它，继续。把死者带到你家门口。家庭成员并将它们撒在白宫的草坪上。我们再也不会容忍了。我们指控你们犯有群体灭绝罪。抗议者打断了科学会议，要求更好的医疗保健。大约20人坐下来封锁了一条四车道街道。被堵的司机变得很生气。到1992年夏天，抗议活动开始转化为政治舞台上的认可。浪费。然而长期以来，政治家们一直在告诉我们大多数人，一切都很好，美国真正的问题在于我们其余的人。
At the Democratic National Convention, presidential candidate Bill Clinton talked about gay rights during his speech accepting his party's nomination. The poor, them the homeless, them the people with disabilities, them the gay, we've gotten to where we've merely themed ourselves. Bill and Bill and Bill. As president, Bill Clinton was not seen as a beacon for gay rights. Activists today believe he did not do enough. He had campaigned on the idea that all people
在民主党全国代表大会上，总统候选人比尔·克林顿在接受党内提名的演讲中谈到了同性恋权利。穷人，无家可归者，残疾人，同性恋者，我们已经到了仅仅给彼此贴上标签的地步。比尔、比尔和比尔。作为总统，比尔·克林顿并未被视为同性恋权利的灯塔。今天的活动家认为他做得还不够。他曾竞选时提出这样的理念：所有人
should be allowed to serve in the military, regardless of sexual orientation. But once in office, he supported, don't ask, don't tell, the military ban on openly gay service members. It went to effect during his first term. A few years later, the Republican-controlled Congress passed and Clinton signed the Defense of Marriage Act, codifying that marriage should be only between men and women. But sociologist Michael Rosenfeld argues that as a presidential candidate for a major party in 1992,
都应该被允许在军队服役，无论其性倾向如何。但一旦上任，他支持了“不问，不说”（Don't ask, don't tell），即军方对公开同性恋身份服役人员的禁令。它在他第一个任期内生效。几年后，共和党控制的国会通过了《捍卫婚姻法案》（DOMA），克林顿签署了该法案，将婚姻只能在男女之间进行法典化。但社会学家迈克尔·罗森feld认为，作为1992年主要政党的总统候选人，
Bill Clinton sent an important message. Gay rights were civil rights. Prior to 1992, Democrats and Republicans were similarly opposed to gay rights. And after 1992, Democratic and Republicans were similarly opposed to gay rights. And after 1992, Democratic voters in the United States started to be more approving of gay rights. And Republicans also started to be more approving, but the gap between Democrats and Republicans
比尔·克林顿发出了一个重要的信息。同性恋权利就是民权。1992年之前，民主党人和共和党人同样反对同性恋权利。1992年之后，民主党人和共和党人同样反对同性恋权利。而1992年之后，美国的民主党选民开始更加赞同同性恋权利。共和党人也开始更加赞同，但民主党人和共和党人之间的差距
really started to grow right around 1992. So that it's another indication that the presidential politics have an influence. This is America. There is no them. There is only us. As more people signed on to the gay rights movement in the 1990s, Hollywood studios and TV networks began to tell more stories about gay people. I'm so afraid to tell people. I mean, I just... Susan, I'm gay. I'm not making any value judgments here. I mean, I don't care the drink is gay, but he is gay. Based on what? The Frank Fontana Gayo meter?
确实在1992年前后开始扩大。因此，这也是总统政治产生影响的另一个迹象。这是美国。没有“他们”。只有“我们”。随着20世纪90年代有更多人加入同性恋权利运动，好莱坞制片厂和电视网络开始讲述更多关于同性恋者的故事。我太害怕告诉别人了。我的意思是，我只是……苏珊，我是同性恋。我在这里不做任何价值判断。我的意思是，我不在乎德克是同性恋，但他确实是同性恋。根据什么？弗兰克·丰塔纳（Frank Fontana）同性恋测量仪？
Tell us about the guy! What is mine? Why did you tell us? All right, her name is Marla. I'm single woman. Oh! So as you can see, lots of things built on one another. Activism around AIDS drew headlines and policy changes. Politicians began to respond to these activists.
跟我们说说那个家伙！我的是什么？你为什么要告诉我们？好吧，她叫玛拉。我是单身女性。哦！所以正如你所看到的，很多事情是建立在彼此基础上的。围绕艾滋病的激进主义吸引了头条新闻和政策变化。政治家开始回应这些活动家。
The entertainment industry began telling the stories of gay people. But does this really solve the mystery of the rapid decline in homophobia in the United States? If political activism and attention from Hollywood were enough to combat bias, wouldn't we also see a faster decline in misogyny and white supremacy? Women and people of color have been fighting for equal rights often on a bigger scale and over a longer time period. There is one answer to why attitudes toward gay people have changed faster than racist or sexist attitudes.
娱乐产业开始讲述同性恋者的故事。但这真的能解开美国恐同情绪迅速下降的谜团吗？如果政治激进主义和来自好莱坞的关注足以打击偏见，难道我们不也会看到厌女症和白人至上主义更快的下降吗？女性和有色人种一直在为平等权利而战，通常规模更大、时间更长。为什么对同性恋者的态度比对种族主义或性别歧视的态度变化得更快，有一个答案。
Not all prejudices are the same. Some in fact may have deeper roots. As gay rights activists Evan Wolfson acknowledges, the stakes involved in entrenched racism in the entrenched subordination of women, are really, for most people, much greater than the stakes involved in the sort of casual, almost unthinking subordination of gay people. So, in that sense, it was almost easier to crack, not that it was easy, and not that it's done, but the singularity of racism, and the way in which we're carved up by race and the singularity
并非所有的偏见都是一样的。事实上，有些偏见可能有更深根源。正如同性恋权利活动家埃文·沃尔夫森所承认的那样，根深蒂固的种族主义、根深蒂固的女性从属地位所涉及的利害关系，对大多数人来说，确实比那种随意的、几乎是不假思索的同性恋从属地位所涉及的利害关系要大得多。所以，从这个意义上说，它几乎更容易被打破——并不是说这很简单，也不是说已经完成了——但种族主义的独特性，以及我们因种族而被割裂的方式，以及女性经历的独特性和女性的从属地位以及围绕它的社会结构中的利害关系，可能意味着你不能直接说，“哦，这对这个管用，所以对其他事情也完全一样。”它们不一样。它们不一样。
of the experience of women and the subordination of women and the stakes and social structure around that may mean that you can't just immediately say, oh, this work for this, so it's exactly the same for the others. They're not the same. They're not the same. And yet, the data also suggests that we are missing something important. While the change in attitudes toward gay people has been building for a long time, the pace of change has dramatically accelerated in recent years. Remember we said that pro gay marriage
然而，数据也表明我们漏掉了某些重要的东西。虽然对同性恋者的态度变化已经酝酿了很长时间，但在近年来，这种变化的速度急剧加快。还记得我们说过，支持同性恋婚姻
attitudes stood at 68% in 2018? Just two years before that, it was 59%. For a long time, such rapid change seemed inconceivable. Gays and lesbians are going to remember 2004. 11 states passed anti-gay marriage laws. President Bush wants to amend the Constitution to ban gay marriage and California courts invalidated the marriage's performed last spring. Now gay activists are debating how to move forward. If you look at positive attitudes toward gay people, the graph turns upward sharply after 2004. When we come back, what drove the transformation and the painful choices that often confront change makers?
的态度在2018年达到68%吗？就在两年前，这一比例是59%f。在很长一段时间里，如此迅速的变化似乎是不可想象的。男同性恋和女同性恋会记住2004年。11个州通过了反同性恋婚姻法。布什总统希望修改宪法以禁止同性恋婚姻，加州法院宣布去年春天举行的婚姻无效。现在同性恋活动家正在讨论如何前进。如果你看看对同性恋者的积极态度，图表在2004年后急剧上升。当我们回来时，是什么推动了这种转变，以及变革者经常面临的痛苦选择？
In 1983, Evan Wolfson was a law student at Harvard. He was writing a thesis. His catalyst was a book he dreaded over Winterbrick. The book was called Christianity's Social Tolerance and Homosexuality by a man named John Boswell, a Yale professor, and it was a sweeping history of the first 4,000 years of the West's treatment of homosexuality and gay people and how different societies and different centuries within this period had treated gay people. Evan learned that gay people had not always been treated as second-class citizens,
1983年，埃文·沃尔夫森是哈佛大学的一名法学学生。他正在写一篇论文。他的催化剂是一本他在冬歇期苦读的书。这本书名为《基督教的社会宽容与同性恋》（Christianity's Social Tolerance and Homosexuality），作者是耶鲁大学教授约翰·博斯韦尔（John Boswell），这是一部关于西方对待同性恋和同性恋者前4000年历史的宏大历史著作，讲述了在此期间的不同社会和不同世纪是如何对待同性恋者的。埃文了解到，同性恋者并不总是被当作二等公民对待，
though there had been many societies in history where there was little distinction made between gay and straight. And so the lesson I took from the book was that if things had once been different, they could be different again. We could change things. Evan asked a deceptively simple question in his thesis. I thought to myself, the main reason why gay people are discriminated against is because of who we love. Who we love is what is disdained here. And so I thought, okay, well, how do we change that? How do we change that understanding? What is the central structure? What is the central language in which love is regulated, in which love is understood, in which love is valued?
尽管历史上曾有许多社会对同性恋和异性恋几乎不做区分。因此，我从书中学到的教训是，如果事情曾经不同，它们就可以再次不同。我们可以改变事情。埃文在他的论文中提出了一个看似简单的问题。我对自己说，同性恋者受到歧视的主要原因是因为我们爱的人。我们爱的人在这里是被蔑视的。所以我想，好吧，那么我们如何改变这一点？我们如何改变这种理解？什么是核心结构？规范爱的核心语言是什么，理解爱的核心语言是什么，重视爱的核心语言是什么？
And in our society, as in virtually every other throughout human history, that central structure, that central language, is marriage. Marriage The very first lawsuits arguing that gay people should have a right to marry were filed soon after the Stonewall riots. But marriage equality, as it would come to be known, was a peripheral part of the gay rights movement. Evan started working as a pro bono lawyer for gay rights organizations in the 1980s. He tried to bring what he had written in his law school thesis to his activism. I immediately began arguing that we needed to have a strategy for including winning marriage in the mix of things we were working on. The idea seemed farfetched. or including winning marriage in the mix of things we were working on.
在我们的社会中，正如人类历史上几乎所有其他社会一样，那个核心结构、那门核心语言，就是婚姻。婚姻。主张同性恋者应该有权结婚的第一批诉讼是在石墙骚乱后不久提起的。但后来被称为婚姻平权的运动，只是同性恋权利运动的一个外围部分。埃文在20世纪80年代开始担任同性恋权利组织的公益律师。他试图将他在法学硕士论文中写的东西带入他的激进主义中。我立刻开始争论，我们需要有一个策略，把争取婚姻纳入我们正在努力的事情中。这个想法似乎异想天开。或者把赢得婚姻纳入我们正在努力的事情中。
The idea seemed farfetched. There were those who were opposed to fighting for the freedom to marry as a matter of ideology and a matter of their own views, and then there were people who, regardless of their own views on whether we should have marriage or fight for marriage, were concerned that strategically it was simply the wrong time. We were dealing with AIDS, we were dealing with Reagan, we just couldn't do it now. But Evan was tenacious. Marriage equality, as far as he was concerned, was not just about marriage.
这个想法似乎异想天开。有些人出于意识形态和他们自己的观点反对为结婚的自由而战，还有些人无论他们对自己是否应该拥有婚姻或为婚姻而战的看法如何，都担心从战略上讲，这根本不是时候。我们在应对艾滋病，我们在应对里根，我们就是现在做不到。但埃文很顽强。就他而言，婚姻平权不仅仅关于婚姻。
It was a strategy. It was an engine that would pull many other rights behind it. If we could claim the language of marriage, we would be claiming an engine of transformation, of vocabulary, of shared values, love, commitment, family, inclusion, dignity, respect, that would help non-gay people better understand who gay people really are and allow us to share equally, not only in marriage, but in everything. As the 80s rolled into the 90s and the AIDS crisis crested, Evan continued arguing with his fellow activists.
它是一个策略。它是一个引擎，将把许多其他权利拉到它身后。如果我们能够声称婚姻这门语言，我们就是在声称一个变革、词汇、共享价值、爱、承诺、家庭、包容、尊严、尊重的高效引擎，这将有助于非同性恋者更好地理解同性恋者到底是谁，并使我们不仅在婚姻中，而且在一切事情上都能平等分享。随着20世纪80年代进入90年代，艾滋病危机达到顶峰，埃文继续与他的同伴活动家争论。
And I would press the case and would be shot down again and again and again by almost everyone in the room, not always everyone, but almost everyone for a variety of reasons. Some of the strongest voices felt that marriage wasn't what gave people out to be fighting for, period. Marriage was a heterosexual institution. Academics who studied gender and sexuality argue that some of the same forces that produced homophobia also propped up the institution of marriage. It was patriarchal, it was oppressive, it was discriminatory, so why should we fight to be part of something that is a bad thing to begin with?
我会力陈这一观点，然后会被房间里的几乎所有人一次又一次、一次又一次地驳回，并不总是所有人，但几乎所有人，原因各有不同。一些最强烈的声音认为，婚姻根本不是同性恋者应该为之奋斗的东西，句号。婚姻是一种异性恋机构。研究性别与性倾向的学者认为，产生恐同症的某些相同力量也支撑着婚姻制度。它是父权制的、压迫性的、歧视性的，所以我们为什么要为了成为一个从一开始就是坏事的东西的一部分而奋斗呢？
There was an even deeper conundrum. Marriage equality for Evan was a way to telegraph to a straight audience that gay people and straight people were actually very similar. They were attracted to different people, but when it came to the important stuff, love and family and commitment, they had the same values. To activists who had faced decades of discrimination of the hands of straight people, this argument felt demeaning. Why tell people who have been your tormentors that you are just like them? Some of Evans' fellow activists implied to him that he was being a sellout. As gay people we should be
这里有一个更深层的难题。对埃文来说，婚姻平权是向直男受众传达同性恋者和直男其实非常相似的一种方式。他们被不同的人吸引，但当涉及到重要的事情——爱、家庭和承诺时，他们有着相同的价值观。对于那些几十年来一直面直男歧视的活动家来说，这种 argument 感觉很贬低。为什么要告诉那些曾经折磨你的人，你和他们一模一样？埃文的一些活动家同伴暗示他是个叛徒。作为同性恋者，我们应该
fighting for redefining institutions such as marriage or the family. We shouldn't be fighting to join marriage, we should be fighting to redefine the family. We should be fighting for liberation, not assimilation. Evan told them they were missing the point. His strategy was based on pragmatism, an acknowledgement that if gay people wanted equal rights, they could not seize them on their own. Straight people, at least some straight people, were needed as allies.
争取重新定义诸如婚姻或家庭之类的机构。我们不应该为了加入婚姻而战，我们应该为了重新定义家庭而战。我们应该为解放而战，而不是同化。埃文告诉他们，他们没有抓住重点。他的策略建立在务实主义的基础上，承认如果同性恋者想要平等的权利，他们无法靠自己夺取。直男，至少一些直男，是作为盟友所必需的。
They were an indispensable part of it. The vast majority of judges who were going to rule on the question, the vast majority of legislators who have to take action. The vast majority of voters are, of course, not gay. We can't just write them all off. Here he is in 1996. He introduced a night speaker, Evan Wilson, director of the Marriage Project of the Lend of the People of the San Francisco Public Library, urging fellow activists to go beyond preaching to the choir. My new mantra in life is, there is no marriage without engagement.
他们是其中不可或缺的一部分。将对该问题做出裁决的绝大多数法官，必须采取行动的绝大多数立法者。绝大多数选民当然不是同性恋。我们不能把他们全都一笔勾销。这是他在1996年。他介绍了一位晚间演讲者，旧金山公共图书馆“土地人民婚姻项目”的主任埃文·威尔逊（Evan Wilson，译者注：此处演讲者名字原文即为Evan Wilson），敦促同行活动家超越“向唱诗班传道”的做法。我生活中的新信条是，没有参与就没有婚姻。
We have to engage non-gay people who are beginning to talk with us. They are listening, they are hearing, and they are largely fair-minded and reachable, but if we, gay and non-gay people, who care, do not go out and talk to them, how can we expect them to get over their discomfort? At the core of this debate was a question that bedevils many movements that seek radical change. Isn't it unfair to ask people who have suffered so much pain to speak the language of their opponents in order to win them over? Evan said, yes, it is unfair.
我们必须争取那些开始与我们对话的非同性恋者。他们在倾听，在感受，他们大体上是开明且可以沟通的；但如果我们——那些关心的同性恋和非同性恋者——不走出去跟他们交谈，我们怎么能指望他们克服内心的不适呢？这场辩论的核心是一个困扰着许多追求激进变革的运动的问题：要求那些遭受如此多痛苦的人为了赢得对手而使用对手的语言，这难道不公平吗？埃文说，是的，这确实不公平。
But there was a goal just as important as fairness. To make things better. To ensure gay kids don't get bullied in schools. To make it easier for gay people to advance in workplaces. To allow gay people to spend time with terminally ill partners in hospitals. The debates between Evan and his fellow activists have played out in many conflicts around the world. If you or your group has suffered grievous harm, you might feel yourself pulled in two directions. The first looks backward, seeks justice and redress, restitution for wrongs.
但有一个与公平同等重要的目标：让情况变得更好。确保同性恋孩子在学校不被欺凌。让同性恋者在职场更容易晋升。让同性恋者能够与身患绝症的伴侣在医院共度时光。埃文与他同行活动人士之间的辩论，在世界各地的许多冲突中都上演过。如果你或你的群体遭受了极大的伤害，你可能会感到自己被拉向两个方向。第一个方向是回顾过去，寻求正义与补救，为错误讨回公道。
The second approach looks forward. It prioritizes change, reconciliation. It often recommends forgiving those who have harmed you. These paths are not mutually exclusive, but there is tension between them. India's nonviolent leader Mahatma Gandhi frequently disagreed with militant leaders during India's struggle for independence. In South Africa, Nelson Mandela clashed with activists about whether white people had a role to play after apartheid was abolished. Here's a scene from the movie Invictus, where one of President Mandela's bodyguards, objects to allowing white officers to join his security team. You represent me directly.
第二种方法是面向未来。它优先考虑变革、和解。它通常建议原谅那些伤害过你的人。这两条道路并非水火不容，但它们之间存在着张力。印度的非暴力领袖圣雄甘地在印度争取独立的斗争中，经常与激进领袖意见不合。在南非，纳尔逊·曼德拉就白人是否在种族隔离制度废除后发挥作用，与活动人士发生了冲突。这是电影《成事在人》中的一个场景，曼德拉总统的一位保镖反对让白人军官加入他的安保团队。你直接代表了我。
A rainbow nation starts here. Reconciliation starts here. Reconciliation, sir. Yes, reconciliation, Jason. Comrade President, not long ago these guys tried to kill us. Maybe even these four guys in my office tried and often succeeded. Yes, I know. Forgiveness starts here too. The same debate unfolded right here in the United States during the 1960s.
彩虹之国从这里开始。和解从这里开始。和解，先生。是的，和解，杰森。同志总统，不久前这些人还试图杀死我们。也许我办公室里的这四个人也试过，而且往往成功了。是的，我知道。宽恕也从这里开始。同样的辩论在20世纪60年代的美国也上演过。
We are not integration. And we believe that you're a fool to try and mix with someone who doesn't love you. Malcolm X believed that preaching brotherhood between blacks and whites, as a reverend Martin Luther King Jr. was doing, was demeaning. It asked too much of African Americans, the victims of racism. In one fiery speech in Harlem, he said, So don't you be fooled by Kennedy? Don't you be fooled by these Uncle Tom Negro creatures? When a dog attacks you, you get a little bit of a fight."
我们不是融合。我们认为，试图与不爱你的人混在一起是愚蠢的。马尔科姆·X认为，像小马丁·路德·金牧师那样鼓吹黑人和白人兄弟情谊是贬低人格。这对身为种族主义受害者的非裔美国人要求太多了。在哈林区的一次慷慨激昂的演讲中，他说：所以你们不要被肯尼迪愚弄了？不要被这些汤姆叔叔式的黑人奴才愚弄了？当狗攻击你时，你得反抗一下。
Mark-A-Mex was calling preachers like Martin Luther King Jr. Uncle Tom's. This often happens to advocates who preach forgiveness and reconciliation. Mahatma Gandhi was assassinated by a fellow Indian who called him a sell-out. Ortec Avnard-Gvariahu and Muhammad Dajani and Israeli and a Palestinian whom we featured in an earlier episode of Hidden Brain. Each was branded a traitor for recommending reconciliation with the other side. I still have a dream.
马尔科姆·X当时在痛骂马丁·路德·金等牧师是汤姆叔叔。提倡宽恕和和解的倡导者经常遭遇这种情况。圣雄甘地被一个称他为卖国贼的印度同胞暗杀。奥尔特·阿夫纳尔-格瓦里亚胡和穆罕默德·达贾尼是我们在《隐藏的大脑》早期节目中报道过的一位以色列人和一位巴勒斯坦人。他们每一个人都因为建议与另一方和解而被烙上叛徒的烙印。我仍然有一个梦想。
Yes. It is a dream deeply rooted in the American dream. In his language and symbolism, Martin Luther King Jr. suggested that the civil rights movement welcomed allies. One day right now in Alabama, little black boys and black girls will be able to join hands with little white boys and white girls as sisters and brothers. I have a dream today. Now, I'm oversimplifying some of the nuances here. Martin Luther King Jr. certainly believed
是的。这是一个深深扎根于美国梦的梦想。马丁·路德·金在其语言和象征意义中表明，民权运动欢迎盟友。就在今天，在亚拉巴马州，黑人男孩和黑人女孩将能够与白人男孩和白人女孩手挽手，如同兄弟姐妹一样。我今天有一个梦想。现在，我在这里把一些细微差别过于简单化了。马丁·路德·金当然相信
in fairness and writing the wrongs of the past. Malcolm X welcomes changes that improve the lives of African Americans. But the tension between their positions is real. Those who champion justice say, how can we break bread without tormentors? Those who champion change say, how can we make things better without winning over those who are amenable to persuasion? Exactly like the civil rights movement brought over whites by emphasizing shared values and shared dreams, Evan Wilson argued in the 1990s that marriage equality could turn many straight people
公平并纠正过去的错误。马尔科姆·X欢迎改善非裔美国人生活的变革。但他们立场之间的张力是真实的。那些捍卫正义的人说，我们怎么能与折磨我们的人同桌共进晚餐？那些捍卫变革的人说，如果不争取那些容易被说服的人，我们怎么能把事情做好？正如民权运动通过强调共同的价值观和共同的梦想来争取白人一样，埃文·威尔逊在20世纪90年代认为，婚姻平等可以让许多异性恋者
into allies. And once the gay rights movement had enough allies, the courts, the legislatures, the politicians, they would all follow. In order to really succeed, it was not about just simply asserting our own and talking to ourselves. We had to find a way of bringing the majority of others who are, of course, the majority to a better understanding of who we are and a more capacious understanding of freedom. And I believe we could do that and marriage would be an engine for it.
成为盟友。一旦同性恋权利运动有了足够的盟友，法庭、立法机构、政客，他们都会随之行动。为了真正取得成功，不能仅仅是简单地宣示我们自己并关起门来自言自语。我们必须找到一种方法，让占人口大多数的其他人更好地理解我们是谁，对自由有更宽广的理解。我相信我们能做到，而婚姻将是实现这一目标的发动机。
Sociologist Michael Rosenfeld says it helped that the gay rights movement had a conciliatory side to it and an angry side. It was like playing good cop, bad cop. Any movement that has a lot of ground to cover needs a sort of more radical arm that is not taking any guff from the other side and and sort of shows the possibility of standing up and fighting back. And you know gay rights movements had that civil rights movement certainly. You could think about the sort of Malcolm X Martin Luther King comparison, but but the truth is that you you can't make progress
社会学家迈克尔·罗森费尔德表示，同性恋权利运动既有调解的一面，也有愤怒的一面，这很有帮助。这就像是在唱红白脸。任何需要覆盖大量领域的运动都需要一个更激进的派别，不接受对方的任何无理取挺，并展现出站出来反击的可能性。你知道同性恋权利运动有这一面，民权运动当然也有。你可以想想马尔科姆·X和马丁·路德·金的比较，但事实是，你
I don't think without having an arm that wins votes in Congress and convinces strangers to to come over to your side and So you can't you need them both Social psychologist Rob Willer has thought a lot about how movements attract and repel allies. He has studied how moderate tactics and extreme tactics trigger different reactions among onlookers. Aggressive and angry protests certainly draw more media attention, but they run the risk of turning off allies.
我认为，如果不拥有一个能在国会赢得选票、说服陌生人站在你这一边的派别，你就无法取得进展。所以你离不开他们，两者缺一不可。社会心理学家罗布·威勒一直在深入思考运动如何吸引和排斥盟友。他研究了温和战术和极端战术如何引发旁观者的不同反应。激进和愤怒的抗议当然能吸引更多媒体关注，但它们也有疏远盟友的风险。
I think that the best explanation for this effect has to do with social identification. So one of the most robust predictors of people's likelihood of joining a movement is the extent to which they identify with the members of the movement and the cause. And extreme protest tactics because they involve significant disruption of the social order and they can involve violence or inciting violence.
我认为对这种效应最好的解释与社会认同有关。人们加入运动的可能性最具预测力的因素之一，是他们对运动成员和事业的认同程度。而极端的抗议战术，因为它们涉及对社会秩序的严重破坏，并且可能涉及暴力或煽动暴力。
They tend to lead people to say, I don't identify with that group of people. I might have agreed with their cause, but the way they're doing it is not the way I would have done it. And so I think that's the risk with extreme protest tactics is they lead people, observers, bystanders, to answer that question, am I like those people should I go join them in the negative where they might have said, yeah, I am like them, I'm going to join that movement. While getting straight people to join the marriage equality movement
它们往往会导致人们说：我不同意那个群体的人。我可能赞同他们的诉求，但他们做事的方式不是我的方式。所以这就是极端抗议战术的风险所在，它们引导观察者、旁观者在面对“我是那样的人吗？我应该去加入他们吗？”这个问题时给出否定的答案，而他们本来可能会说：是的，我跟他们一样，我要加入那场运动。虽然让异性恋者加入婚姻平等运动
was an easy, the truth was, it wasn't really asking a lot of them. In reality, marriage equality cost straight people nothing. Michael Rosenfeld says it made allies feel good to be part of celebrations, inclusion, and love. What was really effective about the marriage equality movement was the way it undermined the frame of pathology and created a new frame of love and commitment and normalcy. Look, the bottom line is that regardless of how you were made or who you love, you should be able to get married if you want to get married. I truly believe it's that simple. That frame of committed couples was a frame that really helped
并非难事，但事实是，这其实并没有对他们提出太高的要求。实际上，婚姻平等对异性恋者没有任何损失。迈克尔·罗森费尔德说，这让盟友们因为参与庆祝、包容和爱而感到愉快。婚姻平等运动真正有效的地方在于，它瓦解了病理学的框架，创造了一个关于爱、承诺和正常的新框架。听着，最底线是，不管你是怎么被造就的，或者你爱谁，如果你想结婚，你就应该能够结婚。我坚信事情就是这么简单。这种由忠诚伴侣构成的框架确实有助于
Strait Americans understand that gay Americans were a lot more similar to straight Americans than straight Americans had fought. Gay and lesbian couples have the same values like family and commitment. And it breaks my heart to know that millions It wasn't like the marriage equality movement convinced everyone with homophobic views
美国异性恋者理解，同性恋美国人其实比异性恋者原本想象的要更相似。同性恋和女同性恋伴侣拥有相同的价值观，比如家庭和承诺。这让我心碎，因为我知道数百万……这并不是说婚姻平等运动说服了每一个抱有恐同观点的人
to become an ally. But it did convince the people who were amenable to persuasion. And it turned out they were a surprising number of them. At state after state legalized gay marriage, what it seemed like an impossibility came to be seen as inevitable. And historic victory for gay rights today, the Supreme Court ruled that the Constitution guarantees the right for same-sex couples to marry no matter where they are. Exactly as Evan had predicted, marriage equality turned out to be much more than just about marriage.
去成为盟友。但它确实说服了那些容易被说服的人。事实证明，这样的人数量惊人。随着一个又一个州将同性恋婚姻合法化，原本看似不可能的事情开始变得不可避免。今天是同性恋权利具有历史意义的胜利，最高法院裁定宪法保证同性恋伴侣在任何地方结婚的权利。正如埃文所预测的那样，婚姻平等远不止于婚姻本身。
Michael Rosenfeld says the data shows... Attitudes towards every kind of gay rights has increased in a similar way, not quite as fast, but in a similar way to marriage equality. And then what little data we have on trans rights also suggests that there's been a sharp increase in appreciation for the rights of trans people and I think one of the things that has been shown by the marriage equality movement is that if you're a gay or lesbian you have more rights than you used to have and that's those rights are important they have ramifications for everybody whether they want a marry or not for everybody whether they want to marry or not.
迈克尔·罗森费尔德说，数据显示……人们对各种同性恋权利的态度都在以类似的方式增长，虽然速度没那么快，但与婚姻平等相似。我们掌握的关于跨性别者权利的有限数据也表明，人们对跨性别者权利的欣赏急剧增加。我认为婚姻平等运动所展现的一点是，如果你是同性恋或女同性恋，你享有的权利比过去多了，这些权利很重要，它们对每个人都有影响，无论他们是否想结婚，对每个人都有影响，无论他们是否想结婚。
Evan says he consults today with a number of other activist groups. He reminds them that each struggle for change is different, and that what works in one case won't always work in another. Having said that, there are commonalities and there certainly are elements of success that I now do try to share with others who come to me from different movements, different causes in different countries, including struggles over women's empowerment or racial justice
埃文说，他现在为许多其他活动人士团体提供咨询。他提醒他们，每一场争取变革的斗争都是不同的，一个案例中管用的方法在另一个案例中并不总是奏效。话虽如此，其中确实有共性，也确实有成功的要素，我现在正努力与那些来自不同运动、不同诉求、不同国家的向我求助的人分享这些要素，包括围绕妇女赋权或种族正义的斗争
or the rights of immigrants, et cetera. And one of those is the importance of connecting with others, of finding a way to bring the other over to your side, to bring about empathy, understanding awareness. Not by sacrificing your identity, not by subordinating or disclaiming your difference, but by finding a way to bridge those differences and to evoke in people the shared values that will enable them to connect with your personal story, your personal reality, and the rightness of treating others the way you would want to be treated, the golden rule.
或是移民权利等。其中之一就是与他人建立联系的重要性，找到一种方法将对方争取到你这一边，激发同理心、理解和意识。不是通过牺牲你的身份，不是通过贬低或抹杀你的差异，而是通过找到一种方法来弥合这些差异，唤起人们共同的价值观，使他们能够与你的个人故事、你的个人现实产生共鸣，并认识到以你希望被对待的方式去对待他人的正确性，即黄金法则。
And it's not easy to do this for anybody. It wasn't easy and it's not done for gay people or for marriage or for transgender people. And it's certainly not easy with regard to race. And yet our country teaches us that we have move, we have change, we have been able to make progress, not that we're done by any means, not that there isn't still ugliness and not that there are still opponents. But to ignore the progress is also to miss part of the story. Changemakers often have a choice.
对任何人来说，要做到这一点都不容易。这对同性恋者、婚姻或跨性别者来说过去不容易，现在也没有完成。在种族问题上当然更不容易。然而，我们的历史告诉我们，我们已经前行，我们已经改变，我们已经能够取得进展——这并不是说我们已经大功告成，并不是说不再有丑陋现象，也并不是说没有了反对者。但忽视这些进展同样也是遗漏了故事的一部分。变革者往往面临选择。
Overthrow the old order, perhaps through violence or revolution, or reform the old order, reconcile and forgive. Which path you choose can be shaped by many factors, including how strong you are, and whether you need allies to succeed. Those who wield a sword and those who hold out the olive branch can both be successful. But if you look at the long sweep of history, the evidence suggests one approach has been more effective.
是通过暴力或革命推翻旧秩序，还是改革旧秩序，走向和解与宽恕。你选择哪条道路会受到许多因素的影响，包括你的实力如何，以及你是否需要盟友来取得成功。挥舞长剑的人和伸出橄榄枝的人都可以取得成功。但如果你纵观漫长的历史长河，证据表明其中一种方法更有效。
The political scientists Maria Stefano and Erica Chenoweth have analyzed hundreds of protest movements around the world that occurred over the course of the 20th century. They found that violent movements succeeded about one quarter of the time. Non-violent movements succeeded twice as often. The campaign for marriage equality told its opponents, look, we share the same values. Instead of force, it disarmed. Instead of arguing, it co-opted. Instead of shaming, it's celebrated.
政治科学家玛丽亚·斯特凡和埃里卡·切诺韦思分析了20世纪发生的全球数百场抗议运动。他们发现非暴力运动的成功率大约是四分之一。非暴力运动的成功率则是前者的两倍。争取婚姻平等的运动告诉对手：看，我们拥有相同的价值观。它没有使用武力，而是解除了武装；没有进行争论，而是进行了吸纳；没有进行羞辱，而是进行了庆祝。
The psychological brilliance of the strategy comes down to this. It's very difficult to fight with people who say they embrace your values. This week's show was produced by Path Shah. It was edited by Tara Boyle and Jenny Schmidt. Our team includes Raina Cohen, Laura Corral and Thomas Lut. Voice acting from Alexandria Masehdu, Galina Abdel Aziz, Maissa Alves de Silva, and Casey Myers. Special thanks to Keith Woods, Sammy Anigan, and Jean Demby. Our unsung hero is Lillian Federman. She's a scholar who wrote a comprehensive history
该策略的心理学精妙之处归结于此：很难与那些声称拥护你价值观的人争斗。本周的节目由帕斯·沙制作。塔拉·博伊尔和珍妮·施密特参与了剪辑。我们的团队包括雷娜·科恩、劳拉·科拉尔和托马斯·鲁特。配音演员包括亚历山大·马谢杜、加利娜·阿卜杜勒·阿齐兹、迈萨·阿尔维斯·德席尔瓦和凯西·迈尔斯。特别感谢基思·伍兹、萨米·阿尼根和让·登比。我们幕后英雄是莉莲·费德曼。她是一位学者，撰写了一部关于同性恋权利运动的详尽历史
of the gay rights movement. It was titled The Gay Revolution. The work of researchers like Lillian was critical as we put together this episode. We're great hotel Lillian and to countless other scholars who've documented this remarkable chapter in American history. For more resources in history, please visit npr.org slash hidden brain. If you liked this episode, please share it with a friend. If they don't know how to subscribe to our podcast, please help them. I'm Shankar Vidantum and this is NPR. I'm Shankar Vidantum and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
名为《同性恋革命》。在我们拼凑这一集时，像莉莲这样的研究人员的工作至关重要。我们非常感谢莉莲以及无数记录了美国历史这一非凡篇章的其他学者。有关历史的更多资源，请访问 npr.org slash hidden brain。如果你喜欢这一集，请与朋友分享。如果他们不知道如何订阅我们的播客，请帮帮他们。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是 NPR。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是 NPR。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。